for the Bachelorette for this season yes
and I'm so sad because I'm such a good
show a lot of good romance in a video of
it yes yes that's what I'm calling it
remember that famous moment though of
course when Kaitlyn did a little bit
more than just kiss she's a grown woman
little more she sure is it made for a
wild TV but you know the Twitter attacks
about this have been vicious I wanted to
go there and address this jewy situation
and be like yes that hurt and and that's
not okay Kaitlyn is fighting back
against the tweet shaming she's faced
after admitting she slept with finalist
Nick during their one-on-one date it's
hard for me to admit it but we had sex
remember Nick he was also a finalist
last year and made news airing his
sexcapades with bachelorette Andi
Dorfman if you weren't in love with me I
think I'm just not sure why like why you
made love it
now on Mondays men tell all Chris
Harrison addresses the cyber bullying
against Caitlyn painfully reading aloud
hurtful tweets like quote every time
Caitlyn opens up her [ __ ] mouth I just
want to slap her maybe a little good
will come of this because the cyber
bullying and the hey got to stop
everybody stood up and it just I mean it
brought me to tears it was really
emotional and and it was I don't know it
felt really good to know that everybody
stood behind me on that Caitlyn also
addresses why she didn't tell the other
men her secret and heartbroken Ben H who
is now the frontrunner to become the
next Bachelor
tells us why he was happy to be left in
the dark I respect the fact she didn't
tell me because I don't know what it
would have done our relationship and it
just did I didn't need to know now it's
down to Nick versus Sean
teacher will Caitlin's honesty affect
the outcome of a proposal and will she
find love I don't know if other people
say that in other seasons but yes I
found look I'm just like I'm really
happy and that's that's the story I'm
sticking